[Music]
let's go to abby in montgomery alabama
what's up abby how we doing
you're doing well how are you remarkable
hey you got to hear me botch the intro
the first time
it's cool man yes i did
i hope it makes the final cut it i
assure you it won't
um james isn't that kind of producer but
it will make the
that is true i'm not that kind of it
wasn't great so what's up abby how can i
help
hey well um so
i guess the short question is i found
out last week that we are having another
boy um this will be our last pregnancy
because i have some medical
complications between the first and the
second one
and i was just kind of wondering how to
process the fact that
i'm not going to have a girl and all
that entails
i'm really
excited about another boy i'm much
better at being a boy mom then i feel
like i would be a girl mom and
everything that i'm kind of like
processing right now is stuff that won't
happen for the next 20 years
but it kind of hit me hard like last
week when i guess because i didn't know
that i
wanted a girl but then again like i'm
really happy that i have a boy too so
yeah
how many can we do that well number one
one that just turned four
so you got one four and then this is
number two yep i'm 18 weeks along so can
we just celebrate for a second way to go
congratulations that's a way to go i
mean that's awesome this is a miracle
baby for sure because we had a lot of
medical complications in between the
first and the second one very cool
and so when i hear people say i wish i
had a girl and it's a 20-year
thought
the idea being girls just
daughters take care of their parents
better than sons do is that your
thinking
yes
so i'm one of four i'm one of four i
have two brothers and and one sister and
without a doubt i can
yes
all right i have some thoughts on that
but we'll say that for a second
um let me write a note to myself
so
how much of this like
what's in your soul right now
is pregnancy related versus gender
related here's what i mean by that
the i haven't not met a woman yet and i
know they exist and so don't be mean to
me on the internets women
but most of the women all the women i've
met
there's even if they've got kid five
kids seven whatever
the day they decide this is it is hard
this is a hard it's it's a hard season
or is this no like this is all about i
wish i had a
daughter i'm gonna go with probably just
wish i had a daughter i am uh
in my friend group we joke that i'm the
least maternal
person in the group like most moms are
like oh i can't i don't want my babies
to leave and i'm like i'm training these
kids to go out like
bye so
i think it's just the fact that i love
your training the ones not even born yet
you're like already i mean
i love it
yes it's just all right so
i will say i can't speak into this
directly because i've
never
been pregnant
um what i can speak into is this
i did have a picture of what my family
would look like
and i don't even know where that picture
came from it's probably one of the
pictures i was born into which is my
culture said this is about how many kids
you should have
and by the way weirdly this is what they
should look like nobody ever said this
is what your kids should look like but
there's just enough pictures about kit
looking of kids that
i just start to think this is what they
should look like
and then there was pictures in my head
of like me and my
girlfriend at the time and now why for
other girlfriends i had or my parents or
brothers and sisters like we just talked
about it
the family i have now looks very
different than the ones that were in my
pictures they were in the stories
and
it sounds like a weird thing a weird
word but
i'm just taking it back
you gotta just grieve what you thought
was gonna happen
and what you hoped for was gonna happen
and that didn't happen
right
right and then
most stop there i'm just gonna wallow in
it and you know i know there are moms
bajillions of them and dads who blame
their kid
let them know i always wanted a girl or
you were the accident or you were that
whatever
um my little brother still refers to
himself as the
the great accident right
um
so i mean i i can there you go there's
17 years between me and my older brother
i see it i i i hate that that's in your
soul you know what i mean and it is they
told you that and you can do math you
know how math works
mostly my siblings telling me that my
mom and dad though
exactly siblings are brutal
all they say is this i want to give you
permission
to go
i want a girl
and i'm not going to have one i'm not
going to have old dresses
i'm not going to have pigtails
i'm not going to
whatever like whatever the thing is
unless your boys have pigtails that's
your boys your dresses and that's
another call for another show
um but like i'm not gonna have that i'm
not gonna have when they get older i'm
gonna have to deal with my boys and
whatever i want you to grieve that okay
you have permission to sit down and be
sad about that
not forever not worth stability but sit
down and own that that could look like
you
writing a letter to yourself or to the
daughter you're not going to have
or
to your future whatever so whatever that
looks like however you need to agree
that i want you just to take some time
and own it what does your husband think
does he want a daughter too
he wanted a daughter from the first baby
so he um
yeah he's he's always wanted a girl but
we just our families pretty much just
have boys so
i mean it wasn't surprising but it was
just kind of like kind of hit me all
it's all at once like
all these things down the road that are
just like not going to happen and so do
it without worry about being clingy to
like when they finally do leave and
not being
a good mother-in-law when they get
married and things like that so okay so
i want you and your husband to agree
that together
make it a thing
and talk about it out loud
the secret
that you wished that your son had been
his daughter
will haunt him
don't do that to him speak it
let it out
by not speaking it we think we're hiding
it and we're getting away with it we're
not
then the second thing is this raise your
boys to be hospitable and to love their
parents
and to be people of character and to
notice things and to take care
you have an opportunity to train them
into what love looks like demonstrably
and you have a
one of my wife's grand plans
is to teach our son
how to pick
a spouse that
like is is
good as a good person
she wants to she's got a picture in her
head where she and her daughter-in-law
are
are friends they're connected at some
like they get get along they are
part of the same gang and i
think that's those conversations start
early
with how do you pick girlfriends and how
do you pick you know how do you pick
somebody who's a that you're
romantically interested in how does it
how do you do all that
you get to speak into that
and the meta here for me is this you're
worrying about stuff that's not going to
happen for decades
i know
is that just you how you roll
yes that is 100
like one small thing happens in my brain
you know 10 20 30 years down the road
going oh man
you're gonna miss out on a lot of life
living like that
yeah
and so can i
offer you one more piece of wisdom
you get to choose this sounds crazy you
get to choose your thoughts
you get to choose them
now we don't get to choose the lightning
bolts the ones that pop in our head the
one that's we're not gonna have a
daughter
and then it pops in oh my gosh i'm gonna
be taken care of
when i'm old by two idiot boys you can't
stop that one
the next thought is on you
the next thought to go
oh my gosh then what's going to happen
and then i need to start planning for
this one all of that is you it's a
choice
and it's something that we practice and
over time those default settings the
down the spirals the 20 years oh my gosh
what's going to hap
all of that stuff
you practice you choose i'm not going to
go down that road anymore i'm not going
to try to control 20 years from now i'm
going to make good choices today i'm
going to follow the process and then in
20 years i'm going to deal with what's
going on 20 years i'm going to save my
money today i'm going to teach my boys
how to love i'm going to show them how
to love i'm going to show them
via loving their dad
i'm going to i'm going gonna make it so
hard the picture they have
and what an awesome wife
what an awesome partner is i'm gonna
show them so much our marriage is gonna
be so good that those boys are gonna be
like oh my gosh they're gonna set the
bar high and you and your husband gonna
live that out like man you get to decide
all that and then 20 years from now they
bring home some knuckle head solve that
then right
okay enjoy your life now but going back
to the original thing
i'm giving you permission to be sad
okay
giving you permission you and your
husband go out get breakfast together go
to cracker barrel and eat too much and
be sad about it and then
you're gonna have to work out hard to
get rid of that nonsense that you just
tortured your body
and
i want y'all to be about
loving this little boy
recklessly loving this little boy let
this little boy know that he is a
miracle
like our family would not be the same
without him
i mean you got an adventure ahead of
ahead of you and i'm excited for you